und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
guten abend eigentlich wollte die
bundesregierung heute einen großen wurf
präsentieren ein großes sommer paket wie
sie den klimaschutz in deutschland voran
tragen will bislang halten wir die
klimaziele ja nicht ein vor allem in den
bereichen verkehr und gebäude wird nach
wie vor viel zu viel co2 ausgestoßen
doch aus dem großen hof wurde nichts es
hakt zwischen fdp und grünen
beziehungsweise zwischen
verkehrsminister wissing und
wirtschaftsminister habeck und so gab es
heute nur zwei voneinander getrennte
präsentation so genannter
sofortprogramme die eine vom
verkehrsministerium die andere von bau-
und wirtschaftsministerium aus berlin
simon pfanzelt es gibt viele baustellen
in der deutschen klimapolitik gebäude
sind eine ganz entscheidende die
einsparziele zuletzt massiv verfehlt
drei monate hatte die bauministerin zeit
um maßnahmen vorzulegen jetzt soll neue
fördergelder für sanierungen kommen die
400.000 neuen wohnungen die sich die
bundesregierung vorgenommen hat sollen
klimafreundlich gebaut werden ab 2024
soll es keine neuen reinen gasheizungen
mehr geben angesichts des furchtbaren
krieges den russland in der ukraine
führt ist auch klar wir müssen natürlich
auch anders heizen als nur mit erdgas
eigentlich wollte das kabinett heute ein
gemeinsames klimaschutz sofortprogramm
präsentieren aber zu groß war der streit
zwischen den ministerien vor allem
zwischen verkehrs und klima ist für
viele eine vertane chance
wir müssen sehr viel sehr schnell
aufholen und haben diverse probleme
aufzuholen und deswegen wäre es sinnvoll
gewesen man hätte sich heute geeinigt
der große wurf ist ausgeblieben so
bleibt es heute bei forderungen
einzelner ministerien nicht
durchfinanziert am kabinettstisch noch
nicht beraten auch verkehrsminister
wissen macht vorschläge auch er hatte
drei monate dafür zeit die
ladeinfrastruktur soll nun ausgebaut
werden ebenso das radwegenetz die
qualität des öffentlichen nahverkehrs
soll verbessert werden ein tempolimit
ist weiterhin nicht vorgesehen
ich muss abwägen zwischen der schnellen
erreichung von klimaschutzzielen
einerseits und den
mobilitätsanforderungen und auch der
akzeptanz der gesellschaft für maßnahmen
andererseits scharfe kritik kommt von
umweltverbänden weil die so genannten
sofortmaßnahmen eben nicht sofort wirken
eher wissen hat leider keine
kurzfristigen klimamaßnahmen vorgestellt
die irgendwie geeignet wären in den
nächsten jahren die co2 emissionen zu
senken denn dann hätte er zum beispiel
ein tempolimit verkünden müssen das hat
aber nicht getan sondern er wartet auf
ein wunder das gemeinsame konzept zum
klimaschutz hat die bundesregierung nun
auf september verschoben
der feind meines feindes ist mein freund
das phänomen ist nun der internationalen
politik ja immer wieder zu finden so
ließ die gegnerschaft zu russland die
europäer wieder enger zusammenrücken und
den nahen osten sind es die macht
bestrebungen des iran die ungeahnte
allianzen eröffnen israel und eine ganze
reihe arabischer staaten verstehen sich
seit geraumer zeit sehr viel besser
sogar ein gemeinsames sicherheitsbündnis
gegen iran steht im raum vor diesem
hintergrund begann heute die nahost
reise von us präsident joe biden es ist
sein erster besuch in der region seit
amtsantritt und die erste station ist
natürlich israel michael bewerunge
berichtet
wenn die air force one mit dem us
präsidenten an bord in israel landet
dann hat das protokoll den ablauf bis
ins kleinste detail vor bezeichnet wer
wo zu gehen hat wann joe biden aus dem
flieger steigt welche abstandsregeln
gelten und natürlich das bild der
geschlossenheit mit israels wichtigstem
bündnispartner die muss man eigentlich
nicht mehr zeigen wo er zu stehen hat
die sicherheitsallianz mit israel steht
an erster stelle
mit diesem besuch stärken wir unsere
verbindung noch mehr wir bekräftigen die
unerschütterliche verpflichtung für
israels sicherheit das schließt die
kooperation mit israel ein bei den
fortschrittlichsten waffensystemen der
welt
auch deren besichtigung hat das
protokoll demonstrativ vorgesehen denn
die gezeigten
raketenabwehrsysteme könnten schon bald
in einem lange undenkbaren bündnis
israels mit arabischen staaten zum
einsatz kommen saudi arabien will joe
biden noch ins boot holen sie alle eint
ein gemeinsamer gegner
wir werden die notwendigkeit diskutieren
eine starke globale allianz zu erneuern
die das iranische nuklearprogramm
stoppen wird
das iranische politiker immer wieder mit
der vernichtung israels drohen verleiht
beiden besuch in der holocaust
gedenkstätte jad vaschem besonderes
gewicht das bekenntnis nie wieder nach
der zeremonie nimmt er sich zeit für ein
gespräch mit der ina quint und geht der
c2 überlebenden der shoah er werde sagt
beiden ihre namen nie vergessen
am freitag wird schon beiden dann saudi
arabien weiterreisen da wird es vor
allem auch um öl und gas gehen in der
hoffnung dass die saudis bereit sind
mehr zu liefern im angesicht des
russischen angriffskrieges muss man über
die barbareien der saudischen prinzen
offenkundig hinwegschauen
zugleich gehen die bemühungen weiter das
ukrainische getreide auszuführen die
türkei hat sich als mittler zwischen
kiew und moskau angeboten auch eine
delegation der vereinten nationen nimmt
an den gesprächen ist ein brutal ziel
der verhandlungen ist es einen sicheren
korridor über das schwarze meer in den
bosporus zu eröffnen damit getreide aus
den ukrainischen häfen verschifft werden
kann jörg brase berichtet
da sitzen sie sich gegenüber die
kriegsgegner mit versteinerten mienen
sie misstrauen und belauern sich doch
weil alle welt auf ukrainischen weizen
hofft um eine hungerkrise abzuwenden
haben sie verhandelt über
sicherheitsfragen eine einigung steht
angeblich kurz bevor in der kommenden
woche könnte es soweit sein
es hat sich gezeigt dass die
konfliktparteien einen konstruktiven
dialog führen können allein das sind
schon sehr gute neuigkeiten aber bis zu
einem friedensabkommen haben wir noch
einen sehr langen weg folgen
die ukraine hat angst vor einer
russischen invasion übers meer hat
deshalb ihre häfen wie odessa verdient
um die häfen anlaufen zu können müssten
getreidefrachter eskortiert werden die
frage ist von wem die frachter dürften
keine waffen für die ukraine schmuggeln
fordert russland sie müssten inspiziert
werden vorher erlaube man keine
transporte durch den getreide korridor
richtung bosporus
sollte die ukraine tatsächlich vorhaben
waffen über diesen korridor zu
schmuggeln würde sie den bogen
überspannen wir drücken nennen ihn den
friedens korridor denn wenn das jetzt
funktioniert öffnet es den weg für
friedensgespräche und andere prozesse
bisher hat es nur die türkische
regierung geschafft russen und ukrainer
an einen tisch zu bekommen der türkische
präsident genießt offenbar das vertrauen
beider kriegsparteien ein pfund mit dem
er wuchern weiß auf der weltbühne aber
auch bei seinem wahl volk zu hause in
der türkei
und mit dem krieg und seinen folgen geht
es jetzt auch in den nachrichten erst
noch weiterhin im streit über den
transitverkehr zwischen russland und
dessen ostsee exklave kaliningrad hat
die eu-kommission neue leitlinien
erstellt demnach darf russland auf der
sanktionsliste stehen der zivile güter
per bahn durch das eu land litauen
bringen
der russische energiekonzern gazprom
kann eigenen angaben zufolge keine
prognose zum weiterbetrieb der
ostseepipeline nord stream 1 abgeben
weil dazu die nötigen informationen
fehlten gazprom habe keine schriftliche
bestätigung dass die in kanada gewartete
turbine tatsächlich geliefert werde es
gibt aktuelle daten zur
inflationsentwicklung in deutschland hat
sie sich etwas abgeschwächt und lag im
juni bei 7,6 prozent im jahresvergleich
die usa melden für juni einen weiteren
anstieg auf
9,1 prozent
wenn hartz iv aufstocker bei ihrer
beschäftigung trinkgeld bekommen darf
ihnen das grundsätzlich nicht auf die
leistungshöhe angerechnet werden das hat
das bundessozialgericht im fall einer
servicekraft in der gastronomie
entschieden
erst wenn das trinkgeld zehn prozent des
regelbedarfs übersteige wirke es sich
mindernd aus
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
11 29 30 45 47 und die superzahl 8
weitere gewinns heim finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
noch die wetteraussichten morgen gibt es
ganz im norden und im östlichen bergland
einzelne schauer und gewitter dabei weht
ein starker wind sonst ist es freundlich
bei 18 bis 27 grad im norden und 27 bis
37 grad im süden die kommenden tage
bringen sommerwetter mit viel sonne und
nur wenigen schauern dabei werden
zunächst 17 bis 29 grad erreicht ab
sonntag wird es wärmer
das war es von uns weiter geht es gleich
mit der zweiten halbzeit und um 0.45
dann das heute schnell update mit neuen
aktivieren und morgen abend
wenn sich bettina schausten und gundula
gause auf sie nach wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]